the missus here I'm opening Ojai was
born ready luncheons ready
we were ready one of my favorite shows
on NBC
now that canceled undateable I was so
aggravated with a guy who are you
aggravated thank you so much that's
great to hear the great Intercontinental
Champion of all time thank you so much
what you love that Norton couldn't be
here they've been amazing he did it on
purpose I think he did - I don't think I
forgot about what happened at
WrestleMania let me let me paint a
picture for everyone out there the most
must-see W Prime the Miz
okay we are at WrestleMania and good old
Sam and Jim Norton were having a show
there they were inside the Elimination
Chamber they had the the pick of the
litter they had everything that seats in
the house best seat in the house for
media day oh yes I start early in the
morning and I start going off on every
single minute I couldn't wait couldn't
wait to get to Sam and Jim because I
just watched Jim's comedy special on
Netflix and I was like I couldn't wait
to talk to him about it
you know give him a little promotion get
a little buzz started about it you know
that kind of thing I let him know the
Miz is watching yeah yeah yeah I'm
watching I I stayed up all night
watching your comedy special now I want
to tell mommy I liked it that's so great
so so then we go through the whole day
it was like four hours of just non-stop
talking WrestleMania at every interview
and I thought you know what I'm gonna be
the last interview of Jim and Sam I
thought this is gonna be it right and
you're probably also thinking all these
other interviews are getting repetitive
it's the same WrestleMania question
aboard right I want to get in there and
what happens Oh
as I'm stepping up to the elimination
chamber getting ready to go on this
interview they go Oh Sam and Jim are
done they're not doing any more
interviews everyone else they were the
only ones I didn't get together so when
I come here today right thinking you
know what today will be the day I could
talk to Jim about it's a comedy special
on Netflix right how much I enjoyed it
and who sits in for him Ron Funches is
here Ron Funches but you know what I'm
happy about that because I I like I said
I was a huge undateable fan thing I
thought the live version was so much fun
thank you was it fun how hard was that
it was it was hard but
also it was freeing because you're like
oh my god you're gonna mess up you're
gonna make a mistake
is there something is it kind of easier
about doing it live because then it you
just do it once there's no retakes
there's no anything I wasn't much better
but you stumble your words you know yes
that that's the hard part
leaving with WWE I will stumble words
because sometimes I get so aggravated
and frustrated that the words just don't
come out like you know when you're
aggravated you can't you can't speak
yeah that's how mad I get sometimes when
I'm in the ring yeah but you know what
but that's why it works like some guys
when they stumble over words live it's
like oh cuz there you can see in their
eyes are trying to remember something in
a script that's awful as long as you as
long as your face because your face gets
all beat red and the vein in your
forehead starts going so when you start
stumbling on words and I like ugly when
I'm mad is what you're saying
you look mad I do get really mad angry
yeah but I believe you guys were doing
it do you guys rehearse a lot did yeah
did you rehearse a lot yeah you just you
know you rehearse all through the week
it was like I was like the closest I got
to be in like on a sports team because
you would just practice practice
practice and then you have your game who
would mess up the most brent brent morin
he would mess up he had a lot of verbage
though yeah he did he always had like he
was always fast talking oh yeah why
didn't you give less lines to the guy
who messed up the most but you can still
mess up all the time yeah funny when he
did it though yeah he wouldn't mess up
it was kind of fun ya know it worked and
that's what was good with me like I
didn't have like I would always have
like just a little joke so I just walked
through do my line and you know I still
the show though was just one line that
thank you so much i bet i always thought
that but it's nice to hear no it is
that's why you got the show on NBC as
well the superhero show yes yeah let me
ask you about live TV all right you've
had your moments but I feel like you
want to ask me questions I will now you
want to ask you some questions
six months later after after
WrestleMania loved me at WrestleMania I
thought it was so funny that Jim wasn't
gonna be here because you told me how
upset you are about that like for months
you've been telling me every time I see
you yeah literally yes I'll never forget
the time you snubbed me and now Jim's
not even said I can't wait to see Jim
Sam so Jim's not here ago what
well I want to know about the live TV
moment that you had because you very
rarely I don't know if I've seen you
quote-unquote mess up in many many many
years at this point but you're you've
gotten very good at getting out of
situations that could be a mess up and I
think that's why they put you on TV so
much but how was the how was the ball
family
Lavar ball the Lavar i was there for
that so what did you think of it you
were there I was there and then I left
like Miz does a segment communist TV
where it's an interview segment and
Lavar ball comes out with his two kids
and I guess the thought was since the
one kid is gonna at that point he wasn't
on the Lakers yet or was he he was so
that this was the first time that Lanza
ball would be at Staples Center right as
a as a Los Angeles Laker right an
official Los Angeles Laker and so I walk
into the into their their dressing room
to go over the script you know like hey
do you want to go over kind of what
we're it's kind of a baseline this is
what we're kind of looking for do you
want to go over it he goes nah we're
good that's okay Carson yes I go are you
sure he goes not we're good I go all
right so I guess we're just gonna wing
it out there sounds like a plan it
really is amazing and I think that it's
it's unique to wrestling because like
nobody would go on SNL and act like now
don't worry we know what we're doing
don't worry about us NL people but
people think with wrestling that that oh
this silly wrestling stuff I'll be able
to go out there and I'm gonna look super
cool it's one of the toughest jobs out
there slightly you you're performing in
front of a live audience and you have
hecklers I mean you're a stand-up comic
hecklers can really get in your head
yeah imagine if there's 13 thousand of
them and they're encouraged the heck oh
yeah how many clubs they throw you out
yeah at wrestling shows they're like you
know more and more give us more give us
more and sometimes it's encouraged but
sometimes there's like one person that
you can hear over everybody else and
it's just like oh this is so annoying
you just ain't gonna go over there and
smack this but you obviously don't and
you obviously and no one else can hear
them besides you right hand a couple
people standing inside them so you like
the [ __ ] exactly so you're like
alright whatever
but uh Lavar like I really
like levar ball I really do I think he
is uh he's just a character and the way
him and his son kind of go off of each
other like Lanza was very quiet right
and Hyrum it's it's very much like a
person that like is like his promoter
and he just you know this guy this guy
this guy this guy and everyone hates the
promoter but you like you can't help but
like Lonzo because he's just a quiet kid
and keeps his head down and works hard
to try to be the best he possibly can be
the thing I like about levar is that he
promotes his kids like he is so
supportive of his of his children like
no matter what they do whether they're
in China doing something whether you
know the kid is dropping bombs on on
Monday Night Raw
he is always stands behind them and
always supports them so when he went
when levar starts kind of coming at you
and takes his shirt off because it felt
in that moment like that was not
something that had been pre-planned it
was not getting up on the ropes no it
was not and I was like all right well
I'm just gonna let him do his thing
because guess what people are going to
be talking about it for months on end
and swear to you I've been doing media
for the past few days for the challenge
champs versus stars and that is one of
the number one questions I get asked is
about levar ball that's how much of an
impact he has people can't people are
always like ah Qun stan levar pol I hate
talking about why are we talking about
him because the guy knows how to create
controversy and create drama that's why
he has a reality show on on Facebook and
you know I applaud him for it you know
it is one of those people that is like
you love to hate him but no matter what
you're talking about him he's a
Kardashian if you will right and as a
guy who's perfected the role of bad guy
like that you kind of appreciate that I
would assume more than most I love it
right for me personally it's the way
that they often portray a lot of black
fathers in the media it's just cool to
see such an active father yeah I mean
that's what I'm saying like my dad I'll
call him every Monday and go dad what
you think the show man Kofi Kingston is
so good what Dad did you see what I did
well yeah you're okay but I mean you
know man these other guys are something
man
Roman reigns
that Superman punch to you yes dad I
seen him punch me right in my face
that's nice thank you you know coming
and then it made cut it make contact
that's great dad that so it's cool to
see a dad who was so supportive of his
children now is there a part of you two
that goes like okay because honestly
your role in that position is to make
the segment work right because the ball
family that's not where they are but do
you really I keep it going and that's
exactly what I did when I felt like
things were getting awkward or weird and
move on and so that's kind of what we
did and sometimes you can't control it
well that's what's gonna happen when
people don't cooperate with you or do
you get to a point where you just like
you know what I'm gonna let you do it
yeah I know exactly what you do and then
you just keep them on track of where
we're going with the story and where we
need to go and otherwise you just let
them be because guess what people are
going to be talking and that's exactly
what you want no matter what that that
clip is looked at all the time on
YouTube has ever looked out everywhere
so sometimes the train wrecks are what
people want to see look at every reality
show out there right the train wrecks
are what people want to see and the
challenge champs versus stars that's
coming out this Tuesday yeah has all of
that right the drama has the comedy it
has a little bit of everything that you
want it has Terrell Owens who is one of
the most dramatic people in all of the
NFL granted he is one of the greatest
NFL wide receivers of all time but you
put him up against a guy like CT how's
he gonna fare in that challenge yeah yes
you like that did you like that it was
so great oh good work how do you react
in your own head when that little kid
drops the end bomb in the middle of life
I didn't hear it you didn't I didn't
hear you know there's so much going on
and you I think I think it was during
Dean Ambrose's music it was so you can't
really it in the in the in the ring
sometimes you can't even hear the person
that is speaking to you like I'm
literally a really good lip reader a lot
of the time I guess there's so much I
did I was I was with you on one of the
pre shows recently and like when we do
the preachers you have to have earpieces
in there turned up way lad cuz they're
in the middle of the crowd and Miz was
Miz came on to say something to Kurt
Angle and like I'm looking at the Miz
and he's going back and forth with Kurt
Angle but he didn't because he just kind
of ran onto the set he
wasn't wearing earpieces so I'm letting
here already so there's no way you could
hear or decide I loves lip-reading
I just lip and I know I know where I
want to go and I know what I'm doing and
it's kind of like I just rip into people
and then when I listen to them I'll be
like alright I think he probably said
something along these lines cuz
obviously is gonna disagree with
whatever I say yeah so whatever his
disagreement is I can just go off of it
have you gotten to the point where you
have like I don't know if it's a chip on
your shoulder but the confidence of
being like you know what I've definitely
pays to be in the spot that I'm in I
think I'm at a confidence level now that
I've never had before and I've always
been very confident but this is another
whole nother level where I know what I'm
doing I know where I want to go and I
know what I need to do there was an
interview that I actually listened to
with John Cena where he said like he's
an elite level athlete he's he's elite
and he needs to make people elite
whenever he goes up against them and I
was I was like God as much as I hate to
give him credit where credit is due
it's exactly right if you're an elite
talent yeah you cannot allow anyone that
comes into your I guess elite nests and
take you down you have to be able to
make them rise to your your level right
and what I would do normally is like I
don't know if I would go to their level
or whatever or just I would just let
things be and now I don't let things be
right it's I know what I'm doing I know
how to get people to talk how to listen
and how to make something really
memorable and that's exactly what I set
out to do like this thing with Baron
Corbin I've been having with a non
Survivor Series we have Survivor Series
this Sunday I knew we were gonna have
zero TV time to do anything because he's
on Smackdown live and I'm on Raw and we
have a match it's the Intercontinental
Champion versus United States Champion
this should be a huge monumental match
and we were giving no TV time so
literally he came off at me on on social
media and people laugh and go oh social
media but believe it or not a lot of
people watch social media bigger
audience than the TV that's sometimes
yeah yeah like I have like 1.5 million
people on Instagram 2.5 on you know on
Twitter that's how many people are
watching whatever I
and so sometimes my friends who
sometimes don't catch raw they'll know
what I'm doing through that so literally
we created a buzz about our match
through social media and it's I think
people are more excited about it than
some of the matches that are have been
televised and been Wow because it lets
you blur the lines a little bit more
exactly like I mean when I watched a lot
of it and just you being able to curse
and do things where I'm like oh okay I
don't know
now I'm not for social media is real the
TV is the TV involving condition - no
it's the TV it's a show but once you're
on your own social media council that's
no they must really not like each other
mm-hmm and that's what that's what gets
you excited exactly the question yeah
okay I was watching you on sports nation
why does Katie Nolan hate you she
doesn't so I was on sports nation and
I've been on that a bunch of times and
so Marcellus Wiley Michelle Beadle and L
Z there's always a banter you know and
and and I literally just go off on on
tangents and just start cutting promos
and so Katie Nolan came on and they were
there I think they were just putting her
on every show just to get people warmed
up to seeing her on ESPN and so so she
came on and I called her sweetheart and
she kind of got thrown out like taken
aback a little bit and so we went to
commercial right after that and right
after that I went over to her I said hey
was that okay she's because actually
that was great that was fantastic that
was exactly what we needed so we came
back and we kind of continued the banter
and we were talking about we were
talking about Bledsoe and how he said I
don't want to be here mm-hmm and so
Katie and I were talking like men it'd
be pretty funny if you tweet it out I
don't want to be here and we didn't
think that everyone was going to start
this whole thing on what's its social
media right Dario because it's real
right and so everyone started saying
like you know there was one of two
things one this is the greatest segment
ever Katie and Miz should have their own
show - Miz is a misogynistic Pig and
doesn't deserve to be is how dare him
call her a sweetheart now what they
didn't see is behind the scenes is
so Katie had to leave and go to another
show because they were putting her on
everything on ESPN and so it looked like
we got an argument and she left the show
so great people put two and two together
talked about all over everything
WWE was calling me going what's going on
here but the thing is like we're good
like Katie and I are good I think she
does a great job on ESPN and it was just
one of those things that you know
Twitter takes its toll
I hope hears this and then responds like
cutting a terrible but no I think I
think we're we're definitely all good
and I've actually been invited back to
sports nation but I just I'm so busy
you're bleeding I'm I am so busy WW I
literally just got back from a European
tour with WWE had time to do my laundry
and then come here for a media tour for
the Challenge champs versus stars yeah
it's nonstop yeah it's kind of
incredible to us total divas and you're
on total divas my wife my wife is
pregnant well yeah with our first voyage
daughter how did you I was think about
it as I was watching it because I I
liked it I've always been a fan of when
people when wrestlers use their personal
lives and like really
injected but was there any part of you
that was like I do not want to talk
about my unborn child as part of this
giving no or were you like yes I wanted
to use it more I literally came at them
and said listen well they allowed it I
thought it was really cool that we can
go in the ring yeah and say and announce
to the world I mean WWE is where we
first met
mm-hmm so you know to sit there and you
know I met the love of my life through
WWE to get to announce in front of a
huge worldwide audience that listen you
know Maurice is pregnant this is amazing
and I came up with the whole storyline
where I wanted to be we're pregnant
I mean how annoying is that Kurt Angle
comes at you and goes listen you have a
match tonight sorry
do that I have Lamaze class today no I
mean like oh you go how terrible would I
be as a guy like I have to go on
maternity leave like I'm on paternity
lore you go to the shows and you go I
would be wrestling tonight but as you
know I'm on paternity that's exactly the
whole thing I wanted but but no it's
kind of not that way so we Maurice is
still doing total divas and she's loving
it she's having a blast honey is she is
she in the same camp as you are about
like yeah let's take this and let's put
it into the storyline man on TV she's
always on board with with whatever she
wants you know she thought it was
hilarious and fun and so obviously WWE
is not the it's it's dangerous it's very
it is like as much as we sit there and
look at it I mean we always tell kids
not to try it at home so you know as as
Maurice and I thought we were like ah
you know what maybe you should just take
it easy we'll do total divas every
Wednesday on E it was great we're
experiencing where you are being an
elite athlete now how different was
working with John Cena this year at
WrestleMania than six years ago or
whatever it was so six years ago I would
say it's not that I wasn't ready for
that that huge of a thing I don't think
I had the confidence that I have now
right and obviously you live and you
learn and through the learning process
now I know that even when you don't have
a title when you're not in a main event
caliber type of program you have to
remain main event level and always not
allow anything to hinder that and so
that's kind of where I'm at now before
I'd be like okay I can get this done oh
I can do this I could do this I can do
this now I'm like wait a second how do I
remain in the main event levels seen
like how do i how do people still look
at me as elite as a top star as a top
dog and I think I've been proving myself
each and every time I go out there and
making memorable moments for people you
know watching the show and making the
Intercontinental title the most
prestigious it's ever been in its
entirety yeah
yeah that's the main goal that I've had
the entire time having this this this
Championship is just making it what it
used to be when I was a kid growing up
the Ultimate Warrior was on the same
level as Hulk Hogan who was the world
champion at the time and right now what
title do you singles title do you see on
Monday Night Raw mention every week
right the Intercontinental Championship
right now let's talk about it Challenge
champs versus stars the the champs that
are on the show because the premise is
like people that have been excellent on
the challenge that you know years ago
we're on real world and Road rules but
it's done these challenges are now
facing celebrities some of the some of
the champs though are people that you
were on challenges with correct so
what's that
interaction like it's great yes they
trust me I they know I've been through
what they've been through I mean it's
great for you you went on and became
this even bigger and bigger and bigger
star yeah it's awesome for you they're
so happy for like the for the successes
that that that I've been awarded you
know that I've had and not only that
like it's great because I'm a little bit
of both sides like you know I'm part
champs part stars I've been where the
challenge champs have been I've done it
so I think they trust me more and I
think the Stars trust me because you
know I know some of them as well
you know Ariana Andrews is on there as
well from right w/e so you know I know a
lot of them so it's kind of like a
trusting and it's great to be trusted
because then you can light fires that
that's the fun part about this too is
the fact that I always get I could beat
you in a challenge mm-hmm and every time
there's so many people that think that
they can go on the challenge and do
great so now we're getting stars the
opportunity and this isn't stars that
are just athletes these are athletes
musicians these are comedians and we're
giving them the opportunity to put their
money where their mouth is and not only
that but they have a chance to win money
for their charity and that's what
they're all fighting for is for their
own charity of their choice and raising
money for it so to put them against the
greatest champs of challenge history I
mean you got Johnny Bananas you got CT
you got Zach you got Wes and you also
have these these dominant girls like
Emily and
Ashley and you know it's it's it's an
Aneesa and then you put these stars who
are NFL Hall of Fame wide receiver
Terrell Owens you have America's
Sweetheart Olympic gold medalist Shaun
Johnson you have Michelle Waterson who
is an MMA fighter you have Kim glass who
is a silver medalist in the Olympics I
mean these and I mean you have you have
Josh the bachelor it's no better no one
can row man yeah is also I mean it's
pretty amazing and remarkable that when
you were doing the reality shows and
when you were on the challenge you were
the Miz
like major given every MS t-shirts to
wear and now it's just cool when stuff
like that happens so that everybody hey
everything isn't it great I love it it's
a great underdog story you would think
I'd be cheered wouldn't you think so
label like man this guy was on a reality
show and he said he wanted to be what it
is and WWE did then he went and did it
and then even when he did it people
still were like no no no and now he's
he's he's succeeding it's the true
underdog story but everyone still hates
me and comes because of your face yeah
so the fame I do good-looking that's
what it is I think about that with you
that why the why is it's just that you
don't carry yourself like an underdog
you carry yourself like it's you're
entitled to it yeah you didn't make
background because I feel like the same
thing the same good the same thing
happens to me nobody treats me like an
underdog everybody treats me like a
douche bag so because you are that might
be answer I mean you're the same guy
that snubbed me
underdog would never snub me right an
underdog would talk to an underdog right
no you snubbed me I have a question cuz
I'm going the other way I'm going from
comedy and now in January I'm gonna
start training and wrestling and so I
want are you kidding me Santino Brothers
wrestling school and January eights my
start day so I just want you know I want
to come in respectful and I want people
to take me seriously but also probably I
want
also probably want to work more your
style I'm not gonna be a high-flyer
that's for sure who needs it if you've
got the charisma the the the gift of gab
you don't need it like as much as people
are like oh this that anything like I
can make an audience boo or cheer and
think it's the greatest match of all
time
like watch watch John Cena versus the MS
at at WrestleMania this year and
literally the crowd is on its feet the
crowd is chanting and honestly we really
didn't do that much we just told a great
story and that's what people want
nowadays they want larger-than-life
characters and they want a great story a
story that they can ingest and literally
look at and go wow what a great what a
great story I think that was that was
one of the moments that really
solidified you because on paper when
people heard about that WrestleMania
match happening this year people were
rolling their eyes and going I don't
wanna I don't think II Pelin John Cena
in my Camry I don't want to see but the
minute that the four of you got in the
ring together people were like this is
gonna be the greatest thing ever exactly
and it was because of the story that was
being bet that's sometimes that's that's
if you're a great storyteller look at
Ric Flair's 30 for 30 yeah an amazing
amazing right why because Ric Flair is
one of the greatest story tellers inside
and outside the ring right and I can
make you feel do you think you could
beat ron funches in a match in a match
after his training I don't know but you
were asking for advice yes my the best
advice I've ever gotten was from Billy
Kidman I was it was 2002 we were at the
Playboy Mansion I just began training at
ultimate Pro Wrestling and I was invited
to the Playboy Mansion I was ecstatic I
was I couldn't believe it
amazing and I saw Billy Kidman there it
was a Tory well since I think cover
issue mm-hmm and I was like oh my god
like Billy Kidman is right there and I
went up to him and I said what is your
best advice for someone coming up I just
started at ultimate Pro Wrestling and it
was the best advice ever it sounds very
simple but sometimes the simplest advice
is the best and it was stick with it and
I was like that's it
but however do you have any idea how
many people I watched quit
yeah I've seen so many people and it's
because of you for you
it I got this gig with with this
television show I got this gig with
comedy a girlfriend you know a
relationship family all this stuff gets
in the way sometimes and you forget what
you really want and where you want to go
so sticking with it was like the best
advice I ever got you know another great
advice I got which wasn't wrestling it
was for acting I was doing my first
movie marine 3 home front another plug
but I was doing my first movie and I was
a lead in it and I was like man I'm
really nervous I want to do well I want
to do the greatest thing and who do I
know that is you know a and an actor the
rock so I text the rock and I said hey
man do you have any advice for me not a
minute went by and he called me and
started telling me and we literally we
talked for an hour and seven days after
that conversation I was so cool calm
collected and readied and motivated yeah
like he's so motivating when he speaks
and the thing that I took the most out
of it he's he just said just be natural
and it sounds easy right but when you
have five cameras on you and you have to
hit a spot and you have these lines and
this dialogue and all the stuff you
forget that sometimes the easiest thing
to do is be natural yeah yeah do that
very well right away appreciate so you
have that down I'm working on it